so let's just say there's a company
that's worth 155 million dollars as of
last april of 2020
regular company not a company you think
about a lot their stock is worth roughly
2.57
think about if that 155 million dollar
company
nine months later is worth not a billion
not 5 billion not 10 million 29 billion
dollars
188 times more
than what it was worth nine months later
simply because
a reddit group users called wall street
bets decided to take on
the big wall street hedge fund managers
go to war because these guys decided to
short sell
gamestop they said it's not going to
happen we want to expose you
and these guys ended up costing them
billions and billions of dollars just
in the last few weeks so we're talking
about the company called gamestop now
this last week
has been a very very rough week for wall
street wall street got wall streeted the
bully got bullied
and game stopped that today's worth 325
if you come over here mario you will see
in the last 12 months the lowest the
stock was
was 2.57 cents the highest it went was
483 that's 188 times we're talking about
look
gamestop has been the highest short
selling company of the year
last year one of the biggest short
selling companies of the year was a guy
named elon musk and tesla
tesla last year believe it or not short
sellers
elon musk hates short sellers matter of
fact i think he tweeted something
about short sellers he says here come
the shorty apologist
give them no respect get shorty
he has no sympathy for shorty but what
is he alluding to if you go a little bit
closer here's what he says
you can't sell houses you don't own you
can't sell cars
you don't own but you can
sell stocks you don't own what do you
mean by that this is bs
shorting is a scam legal only
for vestigial vestigial reasons now
watch this here stay right here with me
mario
okay actually turn around because i want
to show this because i don't think
people are going to believe this
how much you think short sellers from
wall street
lost betting against elon musk last year
again short sellers how much do you
think they lost bidding against elon
musk last year a billion dollars
out of five billion dollars 10 billion
dollars
20 billion dollars you think that much
money pat
watch this according to cnn tesla
short seller this is an article from
this year january 6 2021
tesla short sellers lost 40 billion in
2021. elon musk made more than triple
that think about hum 2020 think about
how much the short sellers lost so
there's a whole business of companies
that short sale so what we're going to
do in today's episode is the following
number one
nothing about what's going on today will
make sense to you if you don't know
what's short selling
and what's margin those two are
important for you to know about so we're
going to cover that here in a minute
i'll go into that first then we need to
know who's involved what topics are
involved
and then a timeline of what happened
with robinhood and reddit those two
data you need to know about and a
certain capital like melbourne capital
steve cohen a bunch of these other
companies you know who bailed out who
what
mentor bill that his mentee if there's a
whole story line too that we got to get
into and how is michael jordan involved
in this
because some of his investors anyways
but let's get right into it the first
thing i want to do to you
for for understanding the basics of what
is
margin there's a movie called margin
call it's a great movie to watch but let
me explain to how margin works here's
what margin means
when you hear the word margin just think
about
margin equals debt so for example you go
to e-trade you go one of these brokerage
accounts
and you put up a hundred thousand
dollars and you want to buy a share
of xyz uh that's worth ten thousand
dollars and you take your hundred
thousand dollars you say you know if i
buy a hundred thousand dollars of this
10 10 share i get 10 000 shares but i
want more
hey mr brokerage e-trade can i get some
debt some margin
well since you put up a hundred thousand
dollars the current federal reserve
requirement is fifty percent and the
most we can do is fifty percent
which means we can match you a hundred
thousand dollars for a total of what
two hundred thousand dollars no way yes
which means
instead of buying ten thousand shares
now i can buy twenty thousand shares
at ten dollars for a total of two
hundred thousand dollars right so you're
like oh this is so cool
this is awesome i am leveraging my money
not a big deal
so what does this look like well let's
just say the stock goes from 10 bucks to
20 bucks
what happens here's what happens your
two hundred thousand dollars
goes to four hundred thousand dollars
the brokerage house comes and says hey
you gotta pay that hundred thousand
dollars back to us plus fees commission
interest whatever they have depending on
the timeline
you end up netting around 300 000 now
why is this such a big deal well
if the stock went from 10 to 20
that's a hundred percent growth right
yes but only if you would only put a
hundred thousand dollars now gone on
margin
but you put the stock went from ten
dollars to twenty dollars
but you also borrowed another hundred
thousand dollars
you came out with three hundred thousand
dollars so you didn't make a hundred
percent you made
two hundred percent that is why people
do
margin which means somebody can make
twice the money sometimes
by leveraging hence margin equals debt
and using the brokerage company's money
and then you pay the fees and commission
right now what happens is the following
that's pretty scary and i've gone
through this before in my 20s
it is scary is the an understatement so
now let's just say this 20
stock goes to 15 bucks this i'm sorry
this 10
stock goes down to let's just pick a
number seven dollars and 50 cents which
means it goes down
25 when this happens
typically the brokerage company when it
gets to around 850 will call you and say
hey we just want to prepare you your
your stock's gone down and you got to be
ready for it
but at around 25 some brokerages are 35
but i'm just using 25 at around 25
if they don't hear back from you you get
a margin call
and sometimes they just go out there and
they sell the stock without even asking
you because they're protecting their
money
here's what happens the stock went down
right from 10 to 750 it's down 25
so that means that 200 000 now went down
to what
25 50k it went down to 150.
you started off with 100 you borrowed
100. the brokerage
says hey give our hundred thousand
dollars back you're like oh okay so i
give the hundred thousand dollars back
to them
what's left to you 50k the stock only
lost 25 percent
but you lost 50 why because 25 percent
here 25
here because you went and borrowed money
so you ended up losing
50 okay that's what
margin call and that is very scary when
that happens now the
the thing about margin call is there's
limited loss right there's only so much
you can
lose now when it comes down to shorting
shorting
shorting can get people to take their
lives which is something that happened
in the story that we'll talk about here
in a minute
shorting is very scary let me show you
what shorting is so here's how here's
what happens when you buy stock so when
you say oh i'm long on
xyz stock meaning i'm banking on this
thing's going to go up
or i'm short on xyz stock meaning
you are banking on this thing going down
so what is long long is you say
i got a hundred thousand dollars i buy
xyz stock i buy that ten bucks i get ten
thousand shares
i'm hoping this thing's going to go up
great that's what i'm doing
short as you say i don't think the stock
is going to go up i think this stock's
gonna go
down no problem so you borrow
okay money from the brokerage house and
you say look i want to do a hundred
thousand dollars of xyz stock go find me
somewhere out there that's willing to
sell it to me
lend it to me uh borrow it
and you get it at ten bucks you know and
you know you you wait for what's going
on with the market because you're
shorting you're banking on this ten
dollars going to seven dollars right
like these all these short sellers were
banking on tesla going
down the start going down right well
let's just see kind of what happens here
if in this situation the stock goes down
to five bucks this guy who was long
loses fifty thousand dollars because
when he bought it was only ten bucks
but this guy that bought it at ten bucks
goes down to five bucks here's what
happens
he tells us broker go buy those same
stocks
at five dollars now not ten dollars
now i have a hundred thousand dollars
that i put in
but i only spent fifty thousand dollars
but i'm getting a hundred thousand
dollars which means what i made
additional fifty thousand dollars you're
kidding me
no that's when the market goes down so
short sale we have
short seller billionaires in america
that all they do is shorting companies
i'll read you here in a minute an
article about
uh uh herbalife that's pretty scary
written by this variety articles
brilliant article
but let's go to the scarier side on what
could happen here
the long guy he's buying and holding
hoping i hope the stock goes up
this guy's banking on the market going
down this is the scary part
about what just happened this last week
with these last couple weeks with
gamestop
so let's just say this 10 stock doesn't
remember this thing went up 188 times
say this ten dollar stock goes to
a hundred dollars okay if it goes to a
hundred dollars
this guy who bought a hundred thousand
dollars worth his hundred thousand
dollars goes to what
a million dollars okay so he's happy he
made what
nine hundred thousand dollars good guy
he's happy good for him
what happens to this guy well this guy
was banking on the stock from ten
dollars to go down
the commitment he made on the hundred
thousand dollars was at ten dollars
the stock goes up he's only put up a
hundred thousand dollars the stock goes
up to a hundred thousand dollars
which he has to now buy those same
shares at a
million dollars which means he lost
900 000 dollars
you see here the scary part about these
two is the following remember how i said
margin call
it's a limit where how much money you
can lose
the most this guy can lose is what a
hundred thousand dollars
the most he can gain is what unlimited
right depending on how big the company
gets
the most this guy can make is how much
a hundred thousand dollars but the most
this guy can lose
is how much ready unlimited
that is the scary part about short
selling so you may want to come back
here to me so you got margin call
and you got short selling this short
selling game
is not a fun game if you don't know what
you're doing well these reddit guys
didn't like it and they went up against
them they found out
that these short sellers announced we
are shorting
gamestop they went on this group called
wall street bets
there was only a hundred thousand
subscribers a few years ago now it's 5.2
million subscribers they started talking
smack about his hedge fund people
they said let's go buy and they forced
this stock to go from 257
to what 483 and in the last three weeks
from 19 bucks to 483 and it's been
craziness right lots of money's been
made
but who's been hurt and what is the
timeline so let's go through this
because i think this is the most
important thing
for us to look at on what's going on so
here's the timeline
of both the reddit wall street bets and
robinhood and a couple other events so
january 2012
wall street read wall street bets
subreddit is created by jamie
rogozinski an entrepreneur live in
washington dc and his motto is playful
with a little hint of what is to come
inspired by earning seasons let's play
later on the model will change to
something more sinister sounding like
it's like 4chan found a bloomberg
terminal
and the discussion board will become
known by shorthand
wsb okay so just remember every time you
hear wsb
it's that ready to count wall street
bets okay later on 2012 the culture wall
street best takes the shape even though
it's
unorganized and smaller tracks people
who weren't interested in relatively
boring investment like index fonts or in
the traditional as i mentioned value
anyways it starts attracting different
kinds of people right even one popular
video early in the
post is a great video in which investor
mark cuban says
diversification is for who idiots okay
april 2013 robin hood is founded in san
francisco bay area you know
initially was just a way to track stocks
but the company is building towards the
idea of being an online brokerage with
no commissions key
no commissions for the little guy the
problem here is
their investors are now the big boys so
their clients are
the little people the small investors
but their investors are the big dogs of
wall street new york so targets younger
potential investors with a mobile only
trading platform
to go on to become a favorite at where
wsb
let's continue october 2013 robin owens
approval from the financial industry
regulator
allowing it to expand beyond just
tracking stocks okay this is big for
them
february 2014 wsb surpasses 5 000
subscribers on reddit
only two years old but they get 5 000
subscribers
good for them they're growing and
they're doing what they're doing
discussion of earnings advice about how
to trade off the news and tales about a
kid who lost a hundred thousand dollars
about betting wrong on twitter
december 2014 after years of development
robin hood will launch his first trading
gap on apple ios store
reviews are positive i think even ashton
kutcher a bunch of different people in
hollywood business sports
by the way i think this is a great app i
i myself think this is a great app i
just think they got themselves in
trouble
so this takes off december 2014 april
2015 by now popular new features
beginner to appear on wsb frequently
the label of yolo short for you only
live once it starts to capture
cultural basement okay let's continue
next robin hood wins the
apple design award la la la june of 2015
august 2015 they they go on droid
next thing you know their users within
weeks nearly doubles
triples from 67 to 176 000 and wsb
meanwhile now has what 18 000
subscribers
2015 bigger names start taking notice
martin
shakarelli which is one of the most
hated pharmaceutical executives best
known for the time raising drug prices
gets an invitation to join
wsb while he's doing a reddit q a i'm
looking at it shkreli said
responds his personality ends up as
clear as wsb subscribers and eventually
someone with his name becomes a wsb
moderator robin hood wins a design from
google then 26 anyways things are
developing and growing they get to a
hundred thousand robin hood is 200 000
this is january 2017
and they're still growing they start
raising some money here 110 million
dollars in 2017. they're not worth the
1.3 billion dollar company they're now
unicorn
wsb is still growing doing their parts
so let's kind of speed up the process on
what happens they raise more money these
guys get 363 million dollars of money
now they're worth 5.6 billion dollars in
2018.
wsb now in 2018 has 300 000 users
and robin hood now has 664 000 active
users
they're growing they're both growing all
of a sudden some issues start happening
retail is slumping nationwide and now
gamestop comes in
game stop shares drop sharply after the
company announces poor earnings and it
cancels this
my kiki and analyst for the research and
investment bank management
benchmark company says he cut his
expectations for the company as the
business burns to the ground
wsb is ranked number two now on reddit
as of april of 2019 they're getting
bigger and bigger and bigger but also
increasingly
heated debates that is becoming its
hallmark later on it will become number
one here soon
robin hood receives another investment
323 billion dollars now there's
323 million dollars now there were 7.6
michael bury an investor made famous for
the movie
or the book the big short announces that
he has acquired a stake in gamestop
before long wsb user takes notice
september 2019 tactics of robinhood and
often other languages on wsb get more
scrutiny from
nbc news anchor outlets and they start
getting a little bit of challenges here
including screenshots boasting about
major losses
and frequent jokes about what suicide
that's when they get a little bit of
trouble on their side in the same month
a wsb user publishes a screenshot with a
list of game style trades and references
to bury's position
on the same stock how they found that
obviously we don't know but they found
it you can do research and find out
december 2019 robinhood launches a new
feature allows users to buy fractions of
shares
making it easier for people with a
limited budget to events in the company
you've seen this video on
facebook it's got a ton of views it's an
ad march 2020. now we're talking
wsb's not got more than a million
subscribers
during that time with the pandemic dave
portnoy the founder of arsenal sports
website a frequent target of criticism
for his company's handling of gender and
racial issues he turns to the stock
market as a replacement for sports
betting and has a large audience on
social media
which by the way he commented on
everything that happened with robin hood
and got four or five million views on
his instagram account portnoy was not
holding him back
so these guys need to go to jail it's
not pretty same month robin hood
experiences a spike
surpassing two million users according
to apotopia etc etc
now gamestop price hits a low of 257
remember how we talked about it earlier
it hits 257.
robinhood raises 280 million dollars now
it's worth 8.3 billion dollars
then over here a problem takes place
in june of 2020 robin hood user alex
kearns 20 years old dies by suicide
illinois illinois
after he believed he had lost hundreds
of thousands of dollars which was a
mistake in a note he blamed
robin hood for suicide this is obviously
not good pr for robin hood
november 16 2020 ryan cohen an investor
and entrepreneur launches a campaign to
gain stop
to reinvent himself i think he ends up
buying 76 million dollars worth of the
uh company uh nine million shares 76
million dollars
and he was a guy that sold this company
uh what is that one company called with
the pet food company
chewy he sold it to i think a pet
company for 3.35 billion dollars
and he decides to get into this saying
we have to go from being a
you know brick and mortar to what more
like amazon okay great
december 2020 robin hood hires
investment bank goldman sachs etc etc
but it is also fined 65 million by scc
for misleading investors about how it
makes its money
and that's not good for robinhood so
they keep getting a black eye
now we are here to today
this is where everything happens january
14th 2021
the battle between game stock short
sellers and wsb user begins in earnest
as purchased by both sides
since game stock surging by 27 and one
day cnbc jim kramer
plot you know credits of reddit users
it's odd it's incredible to watch i
think they're succeeding beyond their
wildest dreams
january 19 not a smart comment to make
citron research a short-selling firm
sends a tweet that gamestop buyers are
suckers
at this poker game you're poking is what
you're doing you're pissing them off
a comment that only seemed to encourage
wsb users even more citron later calls
reddit
and angry mob and vows to quit
commenting publicly about gamestop
january 22nd gamestop trading becomes so
volatile that it is halted at least four
times its
stock search 51 in a day and closes at a
den record
then wsb users celebrate and vow more
with one user writing you ready
guys please hold i got to pay off my
student loans
just crazy stuff going on with gamestop
share surge again and then there's the
short squeeze that we talked about
earlier
and then january 27 to 28 everything
seems to reach a boiling point at once
wsb goes off flying for several hours
and it's moderators catch up
to the volume of margin calls 5.2 and
they're they're now at 5.2 million
subscribers
anyways it's not looking pretty while
all this stuff is going on it's
important to realize
that janet yellen all of a sudden comes
out and says wait a minute this is what
is going on over here
you know and she's been assigned by uh
uh uh by uh biden
you know this is not good now we need to
investigate bitcoin she traps bitcoin
because some of these wsb people are
also bitcoin people so they're like
free-minded leave us alone
you can't tell us what to do type of a
mindset and then there gets a link
between
janet yellen who did speaking for these
guys and got paid seven million dollars
and one of the companies
that lost a lot of money is the one that
she got paid 810 000
so now there's speculation that she is
really getting
involved to stop the whole thing because
this is now hurting
the same people that paid her the seven
million dollars which is the big
that's that's what the speculation is
right then aoc gets involved and aoc
says this is unacceptable we need to
know more about robinhood app
apps decision to block retail investors
from purchasing stocks while hedge funds
are freely able to
trade the stocks and they see fit as a
member of the financial services
committee
at support of hearing if necessary
elon musk down here says what absolutely
you know who else agrees with her
a person that would never agree with her
ted cruz and she says listen ted you can
sit this one out i don't like you
but any other republican that wants to
come and join me on this to go against
robin hood
let's go ahead and do it by the way
today robin was a 20 to 30 billion
dollar company it's not a small company
so all of this stuff has happened in the
last few weeks right
so when you when you go in you know you
look at the fun you know some people are
taking shots reddit tweets out saying
can't wait to explain this week to my
therapist it gets
857 000 likes they're not playing along
and realizing hey we got to kind of take
advantage of this
and play along because this thing can
really you know they're
they're obviously getting a lot of
eyeballs which is good for them
elon musk plays even more just puts the
hashtag bitcoin in his profile
and within one hour bitcoin stock goes
up
twenty percent to thirty seven thousand
two twenty nine you're kinda seeing
what's going on so so as we're looking
at all this stuff
how do these short sellers do what they
do because
melvin capital was one of the ones that
shorted gamestop
they are saying they lost somewhere
between a half a billion dollars to a
few billion dollars
melvin capital got bailed out by ken
griffin from citadel and steve cohen
from 0.72 they injected 3 billion
dollars
into melvin to prevent it from
collapsing
this is not small-time stuff right now
by the way melbourne capital is a 13
billion dollar company
12 and a half billion dollar asset under
management they were bailed out by steve
cohen who was the
founder of melvin capital's former
mentor anyways long story short they
came out and said we got to build these
guys out
and the next thing you know a bunch of
these guys pulled out 100 their money oh
my gosh we can't even do anything with
this anymore
so melvin capital pulled their money out
you have another company that pulled
their money out just a bunch of people
like dude we're giving up you know
andrew left
from citron 100 by the way the stock of
gamestop was short at 130 percent
let me say this one more time imagine
there's only 10 shares of a stock
but 13 shares were shorted how do you
short 13
you understand what i'm like it's
ludicrous
what happened during this last three
weeks so what does all this stuff mean
to
you and i and what's going to happen to
robinhood because they're getting sued
and a bunch of other stuff is taking
place
here's what i have these are my thoughts
about what i'm thinking about on on
what's going on over here number one is
we just had an election and we learned
what happens if you say stuff that the
government doesn't like
they silence you how do they silence you
they silence a lot of people on twitter
you can't put this you can't put that
you can't put that okay
but social media and the voices had
so much power that the government came
in and said hey twitter what are you
going to do about it you got to silence
these people
what does it mean if this happens today
the last three weeks we
learned social media users
day-to-day people have a lot of power
because they have a lot of
voice but the wall street guys
may not have 5.2 million subscribers
but what do the wall street guys have
and hedge fund people have
is they buy politicians so they have
power and influence the reddit guys have
a voice
that war here's what takes place
on one end if we saw election news while
silencing everybody
this could lead to the government
silencing a lot of people on reddit
i don't know what they're going to be
doing but they're sitting there saying
well this is not acceptable we just lost
a few billion
we can't be losing that kind of money
and the people they're complaining to
are the same people that they supported
their campaigns and they need their
campaign they need their money to be
supported on the next election so that's
number one
let's set that part aside next one here
okay
so one side is coming out saying
over-regulate we need new regulation we
need new regulation we need no
regulation that's what we need to be
doing
the other side is saying let the market
decide for itself
one side is saying no you can't do this
because people are losing money they're
committing suicide
yeah anytime you buy a stock
someone makes money somebody loses money
it's a zero-sum game
it's not like everybody who buys they
make money no
guess what the hedge fund guys lost some
money that's fine they lost some money
no but it's not fair because these other
guys that are doing what they're doing
they're not professionals they don't
know what they're doing
let the market decide for itself it
tells you the government wants control
and they're hinting at controlling
bitcoin bitcoin folks don't think
that'll ever happen
but the government's saying if we want
to take control we can and they're just
putting a lot of threats
don't regulate let the market be left
alone do regulate by the way
remember the margin call earlier i gave
you that i said it's 50 like if you have
a hundred thousand dollars the brokerage
will give you another hundred thousand
dollars which is 50
of the total remember that number that
number was came out in 1974 by federal
reserve right you know how many times
that number's been changed
23 plus times which means what
they can change it again if they want to
and there's nothing anybody can do about
it next point the bully got bullied
right we all know the bully got bullied
what took place right now
is this going to stop the only way the
bully
is going to be able to continue bullying
is if he gets the government to protect
them
if they do because the bully doesn't
like it when the rules are against them
they love it when the rules favor them
they don't like you when the
rules are against them so i don't really
know what's going to be taking place
right now with that
what i can tell you is the following
there's really a handful of people right
now
on what took place with this there are
those who know what they're doing
okay and they may have lost some money
they'll come back up because they know
how to play the game
there are those who have no clue what
they're doing they got lucky there are
those who are scared and they're sitting
on the sideline
there are those who are not going to go
in and then there are those that are
researching and learning right now to
see how they can capitalize
off of this all i can tell you about
this is the following
when you play a game that you know
nothing about you can't get lucky
but if you keep playing the game that
you know nothing about
you can eventually burn now for me when
i got into investing into the stocks
years ago i was 20 years old or 21 years
old
i bought nike stock and i got margin
from e-trade and the stock went up 20
percent
i didn't make 20 i made 40 i sat there
and i said wow this is
awesome uh six months later
i played the same game with margin i
didn't pay attention i didn't put a stop
loss
i lost all my money in the market at a
point where i couldn't afford to lose
all my money
so there's going to be a lot of people
today that get lucky a lot of people
today that lose money
my biggest recommendation to you is to
go
research and learn because sometimes
when you lose the biggest lesson about
losing
is the fact that you're forced to learn
i was forced to learn
i hope this entire mess of the last week
forces more of us to get educated about
how money works
because if we don't get educated about
how money works this is not going to go
away
very good thing for some people very
scary thing
for a few people robin hood's black guy
is not going to go away
these reddit folks are not going to go
away because they're very loud
and the hedge fund fund guys are not
going to go away we don't this may be
just a little battle that the
redditors won the war is yet to be
determined
and the war is not you know one month or
one week or
three months the war is a year five
years ten years
the next 12 24 36 months is going to
tell us
who's going to end up winning this war
having said that
if you watch this video i got a video i
did four or five years ago called 20
rules of money if you've never seen it
click over you to go watch it
and if you have any thoughts on this i'd
love to hear from you send me a text at
310-340-1132
once again 310-340-1132 i want to hear
from you
on what's your biggest takeaway of what
happened the last three weeks take care
everybody